[موسيقى]
الفن في ركوب الخيل يكمن في حسن اندماج
الخيل مع خياله مشاهدتهما يصبحان روحا
واحده يجعلني اشعر بالحريه احب الشعور
بانني داخل دماغ الحصان احب عندما يعلم
الحصان ما اريده واحب فهم ما هو
يريده فعندما يجد الراكب هذه الصله سيكتشف
مدى روعتها اسمي شون فلوريدا وانا بطل
العالم في التحكم وترويض الخيول واول فارس
يربح 5 ملايين دولار من خلال هذه الرياضه
[موسيقى]
فقط
بدات الرياضه مع رعاه البقر هم عباره عن
مجموعه من رعاه البقر يجتمعون للتباهي
بخيولهم الامر يشبه سيارات السباق فاذا
كان هناك مجموعه من سيارات السباق سيرغب
السائقون بمعرفه اي سياره هي الاسرع في
هذه الحاله انهم رعاه بقر ويريدون معرفه
اي خيل يستطيع الدوران بشكل اسرع بدات
رحلتي في هذه الرياضه من خلال عائلتي فقد
كان والدي فارسا عظيما
كما ان اخي كان مدرب خيل واخي الاخر كان
طبيبا
بيطريا لقد ترعرعت بين الخيول واعتقد ان
هذه كانت ميزه كبيره عندما اقوم بتدريب
الهواه او حتى البعض من المحترفين اعلمهم
كيفيه قراءه الخيل التكنولوجيا قد ساعدت
رياضتي هذه بشكل كبير فرياض تنا كبيره
خارج الولايات المتحده وتمتد الى اوروبا
وامريكا الجنوبيه والشماليه وكندا وتلقى
العديد من مقاطع الفيديو الرسائل
الالكترونيه من جميع انحاء العالم ل
متميني سالون عن طرق التحكم بالخيل فقمت
بانشاء موقع الخاص لانشر فيه مقاطع فيديو
فيها نصائح عن كيفيه التعامل مع الخيول
وعن الرياضه بشكل عام ليتمكنوا من
مشاهدتها متى ما
شاءوا الاشخاص الذين يشاركون بموقعي هم من
عشاق الخيول وتتراوح اعمارهم بين شبان
صغار السن ومتابعين من الجيل الاكبر
سنا انه امر مدهش ان يؤثر الخيل فيك
فعندما يدخل الخيل في حياتك لا يستطيع
الخروج
[موسيقى]
منها